I got back from a family RV trip late
last night yes there'll be pictures
later in the show and wanted to catch up
on all the news so this morning I
watched their Sunday shows on the other
networks you know to make sure eyes
across all the important developments
good morning and thanks for joining us
this Sunday this week we saw just how
Michael Cohen's knowledge of the
president's past could determine Trump's
future let me start with the Michael
Cohen situation Anthony thanks so much
for joining us we appreciate it I want
to start with Michael Cohen
well I do not want to start with a
Michael Cohen situation in fact I don't
want to waste your time with Michael
Cohen at all because this endless
ridiculous crazed Russia obsession of
the political and media establishment
has literally zero impact on your life
what does have an impact on your life
the fact that we've just hit four point
one percent growth the fact that what's
driving that is a massive boom in
business investment the fact that this
is leading to higher productivity and
most importantly higher incomes for
working Americans that's what we should
be talking about not just to pat
ourselves on the back but to make sure
we keep things moving in the right
direction and don't go back to the bad
old days the bad old decades of wage
stagnation for the workers at the same
time as skyrocketing riches for the
elite we need to be clear about why this
turnaround is happening because we have
an unashamed Lee Pro Enterprise
president in the White House and a
Republican majority in Congress and no
it's not just the tax cuts including the
corporate tax cut although that was
absolutely vital
it's the deregulation it's the energy
policy is the massive change in the
whole climate of policy making that has
led to a surge in business confidence
all of that goes into reverse if the
Democrats win power there was a time
when the Democrats were centrists
wanting to be seen as pro-business not
anymore
they're lurching off to the loony left
there was a time when Democrats were
populist for the workers not anymore
they're pandering to their activists
bass backing policies that hurt American
workers like open borders if the
Democrats get in
everyone knows what will happen taxes go
up the economy goes down President Trump
was elected for one reason above all to
get the economy moving of the decades of
elitist failure that's why so many
people supported him even if they didn't
love his language or his behavior or his
tweets
well he's delivering his side of the
bargain faster and bigger than perhaps
even his supporters expected
that's why his opponents in the elite
and in the media don't want to talk
about it they'll do anything to distract
and deflect from the economic turnaround
which is why we saw their favorite
tactic deployed this morning
chin up they're elitist base with Russia
conspiracy dog whistles they do not care
about you or your life in their rich
comfortable elitist bubble their
detached from the stresses of working
Americans and puffed up with our own
smug self-importance high end TV dramas
set in Washington DC like house of cards
and scandal have completely gone to
their heads
they think their glamorous participants
in some high-minded game not made
journalists reporting the news if the
news contradicts their elitist narrative
well they just don't report it real
people in the real world many millions
of them are seeing life get better for
the first time in a long time but the
ìwhy eyes intellectual yet idiot in our
ruling class simply don't care they
should remember something to paraphrase
that famous phrase of Bill Clinton's
aide it's the economy idiots
tell me what you think of all that that
next Rev FNC and that steve hilton ex